so the challenge is can you write a
joke
using the word time in just 10 minutes
well we're running out of time already
so let's get into it my friends here
you're gonna learn not only
how to write a joke but the creative
process around
creating ideas and transforming them in
to jokes now the name of the game is
numbers the more you write the more
jokes you're going to have but i've
interviewed over 400 comedians
on this channel
and people across the board have said
you'll write 20 jokes and keep one of
them most of the time so just know
they're not all gonna be all but
for today's exercise
the word of the day is time
and now we're gonna hang out and write a
joke together right along with me
comment in the comments if you have some
joke ideas as well using the word time
or based on what i'm writing here but
in the meantime in between time
here we go my friends
boom
so the word time so what comes to mind
when you think
of time that's always a good place to
start when writing is what what comes to
mind when i hear this word or this
phrase or this experience or this story
that i have
so for me time you know i think of clock
you can associate words phrases
um yeah experiences
just whatever comes to mind first off
when you think of time
time i think of clock
alarm
uh being late
some common uh idioms could be
you know running out of time
running out of time
and we're not trying to be funny right
now we're literally just trying
to brainstorm around what comes up when
i think of time i see here zach said
aging yeah aging is one for sure yeah
running out of time
running out of time
on a time crunch is another one
um
oh yeah sasha sashka said military time
synchronization
hands faces on a clock yeah yeah so a
clock has
hands which is interesting and funny in
itself uh grandfather clock
um
late you know late
um
i don't know irish exit isn't that a
thing
timetable yeah point in time time limit
yeah
so see you're getting it
and these comments are coming in
during our live stream we live stream
this every single wednesday at 10 a.m
eastern time so do hit that subscribe
button and come on back
next wednesday
um
and hit the notification bell because
then that'll tell you when
we are actually live we do three live
streams a week on here
so time crisis one moment in time time
after time punctuality time and a half
yeah yeah time out oh yeah time out is a
good one
um
what else you think of time
um
time
pink floyd wasn't there a pink floyd
song called time
times square oh that's a good one there
olga all the way from russia
um
[Music]
sorry my atd um running out of time
so what would be running out of time
um
time to have a
baby i mean a phrase it's time
oh sorry i was trying to make it more in
focus i made it out of focus
um
[Music]
so all right so how can i relate this to
myself time of the month overtime time
and a half crunch time yeah a lot of
good ones coming in here so
overtime
time and a half
um
time crunch so now that we have some
ideas brainstormed what you want to do
like
is figure out one listen to your sense
of humor here so what in your sense of
humor is sticking out to you the most as
a potential for a joke so it's a sense
of humor for a reason follow that sixth
sense so for this one
i have clock alarm clock being late um
time and a half time out grandfather
clock
um time of day time of the month
time to have a baby that's something you
know i'm being in your 30s people say
and such um running out of time
time crunch i feel like there's a way to
um connect this to me maybe feeling like
i'm running out of time being
34. um
[Music]
but there's something to
i think the phrase running out of time
that i can play around with so running
out of time
that generally means that um you're low
on time so now i'm just trying to figure
out how i can flip it you know in a
in a joke the formula is set up punch
line so you're setting up the audience
to think in one direction and a punch
line creates a surprising second
direction
so right now i'm figuring out what is
that first direction so
right now running out of time
uh people are gonna think i'm low on
time maybe i'm
impatient that could also be anxiety
um
so for example with anxiety like
something just popped in my head is
um
my doctor says exercising helps with
anxiety but i'm running out of time um
so you see we're
we're getting there
but um
running out of time
so now so now your job as a comedian the
comedic effect is to flip it so right
now it's running out of time so the
audience is thinking
you know oh i'm running out of time i'm
impatient i don't
have a lot of time left i'm on a time
crunch um i keep a tight schedule
but really running out of time
could be like physically running
so let's just say for example physically
running out of time so what would that
look like physically running out of time
as opposed to metaphorically which is
the common phrase
physically running you know maybe you're
on a track
team uh
maybe you're in a marathon
maybe you're
running
from police okay that's a funny twist
there
so maybe
running out of time something with jail
is uh time serving time
running out of serving time so maybe
there's something with
um
you know i mean this is just silly right
now fleeing from
police
is
running
out
of serving time
okay hey we're we're getting there we're
honing it in here you know it's all a
process
but we're getting on the right track
here
fleeing from police running out of time
maybe i always ran out of time so ran
out of time
ran out of time where would you run out
of time
um
so maybe if there was like
um if there was like a marathon
with time limit
okay so here we go
i tried and maybe it's not a marathon
but
um
i tried
to finish
the marathon
within
five hour
time limit
but
i ran
out
of
time
so now you're starting to see it coming
into like
oh ran out of time on a test that's
interesting or alan
or ran out of time time magazine i see
joyce put time magazine in there
uh i tried to finish the marathon within
five hours
time limit but i ran out of time i
almost like
the time magazine maybe i ran out of
time magazines um
um maybe it's
my favorite
magazine
is no longer
in print
ran out
okay how about
this um i mean
target said
they
no long target said they no longer carry
my favorite magazine they ran out of
time so something with the wording
[Music]
try to finish the marathon
or how about this i tried to beat
my
wife's marathon running time but ran out
of time
so how about
i tried to beat oh and we're at the
buzzer here we're at the buzzer
so i tried to beat
the
world record what would be running like
the marathon world record
but ran
out of time
okay so
it's not
the best joke ever but you see
the process you see i just realized how
shaky that camera is um
but you see the process here for for
like writing a joke it's basically
if you're trying to do it just off a
random experience you have or just a
random word like we do here every single
wednesday where we get a random word and
write
jokes using that word just as a writing
exercise
basically
you associate you brainstorm all the
different connections all the different
things you think of positive or negative
doesn't have to be funny you're just
getting a bunch of ideas out on paper
first
and then you pick the one that is
standing out to you the most and your
sixth sense of
what is maybe the best potential for a
joke
because i saw running out of time
that felt like a clear way that i'd be
able to flip
the misdirect there as we talked about
earlier in this video about you creating
that misdirect in your jokes so
for this
one i tried to beat the marathon world
record but i ran out of time
so
i'm not i'm not gonna be doing this one
on stage anytime soon but
for the sake of a joke this one's like a
funny like wordplay joke you're
basically like
reinterpreting the phrase ran out of
time
so you know it's just it's a nice little
silly joke but you know for a little 10
minute exercise this is always a great
way to just get the juices flowing but
just understand that
you're gonna write 20 jokes and end up
keeping one of them so this is just one
of the many jokes you could write using
the word time but do comment with yours
and subscribe to this channel and hit
the notification bell so you can get
alerted when we do this live stream
every single wednesday at 10 a.m
but until then
it's time to write
all
right subscribe